We’ve all seen the occasional child playing
football accidentally run the wrong way on
the field, and if you watch enough T-ball,
you might even occasionally see a kid run
the wrong way on the base paths.
It turns out, there was once a Major League
Baseball player who did this, only he did
it on purpose.
The man was Herman “Germany” Schaefer,
who also had other nicknames given to him
such as “Dutch” and “The Prince”.
Schaefer was a notorious prankster in baseball
who would do things like wear rain coats or
carry a lantern out onto the field during
the game, trying to hint to the umpire that
they should call the game because of rain
or darkness (more of his zany antics in the
Bonus Facts below).
One of his more memorable antics was to steal
first base from second (possibly twice, though
there is no documented proof of the first
instance, just a story from a fellow player,
Davy Jones.)
Schaefer is the only known person to ever
steal first in a Major League game and will
remain so, because, probably due to Schaefer,
a new rule was written shortly after his death
at the age of 42 in 1919 from a “brain hemorrhage”
and complications due to tuberculosis.
Rule 52, Section 2, which is now Rule 7.08i:
After he has acquired legal possession of
a base, [if] he runs the bases in reverse
order for the purpose of confusing the defense
or making a travesty of the game… [the]
umpire shall immediately call “Time” and
declare the runner out…
The supposed first instance of Schaefer stealing
first, according to Davy Jones, occurred in
a game against Cleveland around 1908, with
the exact date unknown.
With a runner on third late in the game, Schaefer
stole second hoping to draw a throw from the
catcher so that the runner on third, Davy
Jones, could try and steal home.
Jones gave the following account of what happened
next in The Glory of Their Times, by Larry
Ritter:
So now we had men on second and third.
Well, on the next pitch Schaefer yelled, ‘Let’s
try it again!’
And with a blood-curdling shout he took off
like a wild Indian back to first base, and
dove in headfirst in a cloud of dust.
He figured the catcher might throw to first
— since he evidently wouldn’t throw to
second — and then I would come home same
as before.
But nothing happened.
Nothing at all.
Everybody just stood there and watched Schaefer,
with their mouths open, not knowing what the
devil was going on.
The umpires were just as confused as everybody
else.
However, it turned out that at that time there
wasn’t any rule against a guy going from
second back to first, if that’s the way
he wanted to play baseball, so they had to
let it stand.
So there we were, back where we started, with
Schaefer on first and me on third.
And on the next pitch, darned if he didn’t
let out another war whoop and take off again
for second base.
By this time the Cleveland catcher evidently
had enough, because he finally threw to second
to get Schaefer, and when he did I took off
for home and both of us were safe.
On August 4, 1911, Schaefer, playing for the
Washington Senators, pulled the same stunt
with less success, but at least this time
documented in the newspapers.
In this instance, it was the bottom of the
ninth with a similar situation as above.
There was a runner, Clyde Milan, on third
who represented the winning run of the game
(it was tied 0-0), and Schaefer on first.
Schaefer broke for second and made it, but
this failed to illicit a throw from White
Sox catcher Fred Payne, as you might expect
in the bottom of the ninth in a 0-0 tie where
a runner on second is meaningless to the outcome
of the game when there is already a runner
on third.
On the very next pitch Schaefer stole first,
again without drawing a throw.
This brought the skipper of the White Sox,
Hugh Duffy, out to argue with the umpires
about allowing Schaefer to do this.
While Duffy was still arguing with umpire
Tommy Connolly, Schaefer broke for second,
this time getting caught in a run-down, at
which point Milan tried to steal home, but
was thrown out ending the inning.
Not to be dissuaded, Schaefer argued with
the umpire that this shouldn’t have counted
because at the time of the play, the White
Sox had ten team members on the field, though
of course Hugh Duffy hadn’t played in a
game since 1908.
The umpires didn’t listen to his arguments
and ruled that the play stood, as did his
steal from second to first base because, at
the time, there was no rule against it.
The Senators went on to win the game 1-0 anyway.
Besides using raincoats to try to get games
called because of rain, Schaefer was also
known to occasionally wear galoshes and sometimes
to also bring an umbrella out, on at least
one instance even up to bat as if he was going
to use it to bat.
One of the instances where he wore a raincoat
got him ejected from the game.
Another antic that got him ejected once was
wearing an extremely fake bushy black moustache
up to bat.
Generally, though, umpires gave Schaefer a
lot of rope before they’d eject him, as
reported in Sporting Life in 1912: “Schaefer
is such a hit with the crowds that the umpires
are giving him every liberty to do as he pleases.”
After hitting a home run out of Columbia Park
in Philadelphia, Schaefer chose to carry his
bat around the bases with him acting as if
it was a gun and that he was shooting the
pitcher Rube Waddell with it.
On June 24, 1906, Schaefer supposedly called
his shot (again a story from Davy Jones, but
at least this time it can be verified that
Schaefer did hit the home run).
With the Tigers down by one run with two outs
in the ninth, Schaefer supposedly yelled “Ladies
and gentlemen, you are now looking at Herman
Schaefer, better known as ‘Herman the Great,’
acknowledged by one and all to be the greatest
pinch-hitter in the world.
I am now going to hit the ball into the left
field bleachers.
Thank you.”
This was quite a claim from a player who at
that point only had 2 home runs in his career.
Schaefer then hit the first pitch off of Doc
White into the left field bleachers.
This is where his showmanship really kicked
in.
Rather than just trot around the bases, Schaefer
made diving, headfirst slides into each base.
This all was recorded in newspapers at the
time.
Davy Jones went on to say that after getting
up from each base, Schaefer had called out
his progress as if he was in a horse race,
though few in the audience could hear him.
“At the half, Schaefer leads by a length!…
Schaefer leads by a mile!… Schaefer wins
by a nose!” Jones said that after diving
into home Schaefer stood up and called out,
“Ladies and Gentlemen, this concludes this
afternoon’s performance.
I thank you for your kind attention.”
This sort of thing wasn’t that rare for
Schaefer, who liked to tell people he was
psychic, and would often try to predict what
was about to happen on the field.
Most of the time, he was wrong, but, of course,
as the late great Hall of Fame baseball announcer
Dave Niehaus use to say “Nobody remembers
those times, they only remember when you’re
right”.
Another common off-the-field antic of Schaefer,
recalled by Ty Cobb, was Schaefer’s practice
of holding running conversations with strangers
on the street, while continuing to walk as
he passed them and conversed, such that at
the end of it, both he and the stranger would
have to be screaming at the top of their lungs
to hear each other from so far away.
Trying to be polite, most people would continue
on with the conversation until this happened.
As Cobb stated, at the end “all street traffic
would have stopped to listen open-mouthed
to the dialogue and Germany never considered
the stunt a complete success unless he still
had the mother screeching answers when we
were half a block away.”
In October of 1914, Schaefer randomly showed
up in Court to defend some homeless drunkards
who were to be charged that day.
His principle argument was that “these poor
souls should not be sentenced to 30 days in
jail for an offense that a millionaire would
be sent home in a cab for.”
The judge sided with Schaefer and let the
drunkards go.
Schaefer then took them all out to dinner.
About what he’d do after retiring from baseball
(which he never got the chance to do, because
of his early death while still a scout), Schaefer
once said in an interview he’d like to buy
a saloon, “Not a big gaudy place, but a
cozy spot where my friends can enjoy a glass
of beer and a sociable evening.
And along about 10 o’clock every evening
I want one of my pals to say to the bartender
on duty, ‘Where’s old Schaef tonight?’
And I want my bartender to be able to say,
‘He’s upstairs, drunk.'”